let's talk about the censorship issues
and because of the lockdown
the mass social engineering i have this
story from theblaze.com now i emphasize
the blaze
this is glenn beck conservative
host of progressive media accounts claim
they've been arbitrarily demonetized by
youtube
widespread crackdown question mark the
longest time it was conservatives
who were getting nuked predominantly and
now it seems to be swallowing up many
progressives
they're not going after the
establishment elite types though they're
going after those who criticize
joe biden the blaze says several
independent progressive media
personalities spoke out recently
claiming their youtube accounts
were arbitrarily censored by the video
platform for publishing or covering
content deemed harmful
independent journalist caitlin johnstone
first reported on the news further
advancing speculation that the
google-owned video company is engaging
in a widespread content
crackdown johnstone wrote in a blog post
wednesday
that progressive commentators graham
elwood the progressive soapbox
the convo couch frank analysis hannah
reloaded and cyber even 531
have all received notifications from
youtube that their videos are no longer
permitted to earn money through the
platform's various monetization features
as has ford fisher a respected
freelancer
who films u.s political demonstrations
what we're seeing right now
again whether intentional or not we
can't go to the bar
we can't go to restaurants and talk to
talk to other people on the ground
all we can do is go on twitter and see
the radicalization
you can see them screaming your face
over and over again insurrection
insurrection insurrection
i know people in chicago who have no
business in politics people who spend
their lives just like working behind a
bar at a bar and don't care for politics
and they love football
all of a sudden now the only thing they
talk about is why trump was bad
and why we need all of this far-left
policy because the only social
interactions they're actually having
are online now i will take this moment
to stress
you didn't think they were going to come
for progressives a lot of people thought
it was only going to be conservatives
the reality is
most of us who are advocating for free
speech including many conservatives said
they will come for you they don't like
you so go to timcast.com become a member
and provide us that shield because they
will ban us
i'm my facebook was shut down i was just
on the convo couch one of the ones they
listed who are great guys super leftists
they they were working with me they were
talking about they loved what we did
down and reoccupied they were actually
trying to work towards a solution they
weren't controlled opposition like aoc
but you go back to history i mean the
second the communists take over the
first people they kill are the
intellectuals the academics
all the true believers they don't need
them anymore who fermented the
revolution in the first place exactly
a threat to their people exactly exactly
the trotsky's whatever and i remember
getting demonetized a few years ago and
a lot of people you know kind of
celebrating it i'm like this is going to
hit you
and i've been saying this for years i've
been we we were even talking about this
point this exact point just a few weeks
ago saying that a lot of the leftists
are going to get hit soon especially
with the establishment coming in
it's happening no longer needing them
and no longer needing them and and i
even tweeted today i feel sorry this
happened and i
and i think they shouldn't be censored
even though i don't believe what they
believe in it doesn't matter the
principle still stands
the ideas should be fought uh through
better ideas and
sadly that's not happening and it's
devastating when you get demonetized i
know
a lot of companies independent media
that haven't come back from it
that can't operate anymore don't operate
anymore
and many times they are a lot better
than
the trash and the division than the
agenda that they're pushing on the
mainstream media and we're going to have
less and less
of that i got i got real mad today
because
we're getting news about these stimulus
checks they're they're now going to
means test them so joe biden
the democrats told everybody vote the
democrats get them in and you're going
to get two grand
then they said well we actually mean
fourteen hundred it's it's a supplement
to the six hundred you already got
and then i rolled my eyes i was like
okay okay fine fine i get it many
progressives are outraged
now they're saying well i mean we didn't
mean everyone we just meant 1400 checks
to those who make
less than 50k a year which is it keeps
changing
now that's important for people it's
going to affect your life
what was cnn talking about all day no
matter
taylor green what was on what's the top
headline story for everybody what's all
they're talking about is marjorie taylor
green i don't care no disrespect to her
i know
the left wants to bring it i don't know
a whole lot about her i think she said
dumb things but she's a freshman
congresswoman
she is not of that much political
consequence for them to to just
trying to hammer in but you know what it
is it is what i was saying how they how
they isolate us
then they hammer in these ideas which
tribe are you in
they say you know she's bad right you
must announce her right republicans go
right along with it they voted
11 republicans voted to strip over
committees this is what we're getting
instead of being told about why we're
being shut down why we're being
strangled out why our businesses are
destroyed
they're saying look at the nasty mean
person on the internet
i i don't care they've perfected social
engineering i mean it's like you know
bread and circuses
like you said the social isolation i
mean it's coming down to a science in
terms of how they're controlling people
and i'm meeting people in my day-to-day
life that are just completely hysterical
over coveted fears
they're just dehumanizing without
controlling people but making them
mentally
mentally ill you're right it's a mental
illness absolutely right i think a lot
of these representatives
that are supposed to be representing us
suffer from narcissistic personality
disorder
i mean everything is me me me look at
what i did look at this and
and this is a textbook definition and
they keep forgetting they're supposed to
be representing the people who are
actually struggling out there and
they're not doing that right
right exactly well i can only imagine
it's going to get worse
if they're coming for progressives that
means they're the
the the path which we can walk on online
on youtube
on twitter is getting ever narrower yeah
but water flows whether there's a path
for it or not
so if if they try and stifle this path
another one will be
formed we talk about it almost daily
that's why i built you know that's why
we are all building timcast.com
and encouraging people to join because
something i should have done a long time
ago i mean i had the website but it was
just some like generic website that like
re-hosted videos
now we're doing exclusive content and
trying to actually actually build
something
out probably was dumb of us not to do a
long time ago to realize that we can't
rely
on other people's platforms when they're
massive monopolistic
and they have insane views and they ban
people for insane reasons and of course
they're going to ban us at some point
that's why you can't give up because
if if everything was working they
wouldn't need the propaganda they
wouldn't need the gas lighting they
wouldn't need all this
this massive disinformation they're
obviously worried that's why they keep
moving the new horizons so i'm sure
they're going to come after
your website now to get you de-listed
with either the domains or the servers
or whatever it is so
the goal posts are moving in a good way
but it's also it's it's we're in a
constant chase essentially
one of these individuals who got
demonetized has a really excellent video
that says tim poole just about creams
his pants over capital
what does it say capital building riot
oh okay i'm i'm sure
this looks like it's a really old video
too that has nothing to do
with wow it looks like she faked it
because it's a video of me in
philadelphia and i haven't we haven't
been there in a very long time in fact
it's the
it's the old set from 2018. so i'm
wondering what that has to do with
anything having to do with the riot
and she's showing clips that's maybe
that's why she got she got banned maybe
maybe the reality is some of these
people just make fake content i guess
there are some bad apples and they
deserve to be called out a hundred
percent there's a lot of snake oil
salesmen that that do
things that are not genuine that are not
good but when you compare
the the harm to mainstream media it's
absolutely nothing
and if we're going to scrutinize
independent media let's scrutinize all
media
including the mainstream media at least
make it fair at least make it a free
market where
the same rules apply to everyone they
don't the there's different rules
applying to this channel
my channel and all the other independent
media channels out there
and mainstream media doesn't need to
play by all any of them they could show
whatever they want
there's cnn individuals eating brains
human brains
on national television that's that's
okay
they're they're surprised by the way
yeah well why do you think they maybe
that's what
the with a little little wacky there
they blew up q and on they made it it
would be this massive issue that it
really wasn't and they used it as their
you know cassius belly to declare war on
independent media outlets independent
journalists because anyone who could be
promoting anything outside the orthodoxy
outside the establishment's narrative
must be promoting dangerous conspiracy
theories or anything that's wrong think
so so this this this guy reza aslan
outrages hindus by eating human brains
in cnn documentary he
he really did this he went to india and
cnn tv
this guy is still a verified user on
these platforms he was posting extremely
messed up things with the covington kids
this guy routinely posts inflammatory
and and damn near incitement like when
you know let's just put it that way i
think there's been a few instances where
people were shocked that
to twitter didn't ban him or take his
stuff down he's been accused many times
of threatening violence against
individuals because of their political
ideas you know i do i do think that
i mean this sincerely i think eating the
brain maybe
broke his psyche i don't no no i don't
mean like he ate the brain in it and it
poisoned him i mean
you can't come back from that but his t
levels are through the roof right but
you know listen listen
he did something on tv it's almost like
he was sitting there and the camera was
on and they were like do it eat the
brain come on you want to be you want to
be able to you know you probably had a
cnn producer being like well you know
you want the show you want to do good
i want ratings i wouldn't be surprised
if he has ptsd and he broke down and
cried afterwards
because they pushed him beyond what
humans a regular human can do i think
the cannibal grabbed him or like like
threw him down and started yelling no no
no he didn't
i thought he was trying to get up no no
no no the cannibal was acting wild and i
think did aggress
at him in some way but he chose to eat
the brain voluntarily got it and it was
it was a
small piece of charred brain that he
eats and i don't think eating the brain
gave him like
what is it what is it called
encephalopathy is that what is uh does
it give you like the shakes
i don't think it like poisoned him i
think it mentally broke him
and now he's basically like lost it from
eating brain it was the trauma it wasn't
so much what i ate yeah yeah because
like imagine you're in this situation
where you're powerless
you have a company you have a contract
to say do it you have to it's your
contract eat the brain
and then you're like i guess i have to
and then you do it you can
never come back from that for the rest
of his life the dude's a cannibal he
could have taken down cnn just been like
these guys wanted me to become a
cannibal on air and like you know that
would have been the end of them
he's a cannibal he is a cannibal yeah
but and
and you know i know we're kind of
derailing but he's become this really
vile individual on the internet and we
talked about the the mind virus how
people are just
really nasty and demoralized and what
he's doing
is absolutely a very large component of
the nastiness and i have to wonder if
what we saw from him eating brain is a
really good example of how
a lot of people feel but on lower levels
they feel they're forced to say these
things
they have no choice how many people
genuinely agree there was a woman
who posted you know she was voting for
all white people white people to be put
on a barge and kicked out to sea
and a white guy responded with like oh
man i would volunteer for that and it's
like
does he really agree with that or does
he cry himself to bed at night
while he literally advocates for himself
being exiled on a boat
look at the self-hate look at the the
the disparaging
this this nasty self-harm that's being
glory
you know glories on them on the media
it's a virtue
on social media that that this is
somehow a good thing
it's it's not you should be confident
you should respect yourself
because only when you respect yourself
you could only then truly respect
others and until you start having you
know confidence and and love and
compassion for yourself
how can you have it for anyone else
they've tied social status to either
being a victim or either just being you
know self-hating for the most part and
that's
you rise to the ranks of society if
you've had so many different traumatic
experience that you can you know like
like aoc
basically using your sexual assault when
questioned on policy issues i mean
that's what's happening in society
there's no there's no virtue anymore and
there's no social uh status assigned to
being an independent
healthy free thinking adult it's a sign
of being a child exactly or if yeah a
follower
it's it's not a child score it's your
follower account it's your likes it's
your retweets your ratings
so this guy's social credit right this
guy and now it's visible so this guy
reza
my opinion on this brain eating thing
was that vice was really big
and they were like you want to beat vice
right you want to be big because i i'll
tell you this when i left vice
i probably had a thousand people say
what can we do to
to get that you know that kind of zeal
that kind of enthusiasm that kind of
coolness that
edginess yeah so along comes this dude
and he ate
human brain i feel like that is the the
apex of desperation for social
acceptance
he wanted to be cool and edgy like vice
he wanted to fit in and have a big show
with tons of ratings and be famous so he
literally ate
human brain he could never come back for
that it broke him
and now the reason i hammer that point
is think about the more
the the smaller instances where people
do this do the stuff the false
accusations
the the defense of people the the you
know the people who pile on say
attacking brett kavanaugh when come on
what's saying people
thought those allegations about him
lining up outside of a dormitory
game rapes gang-raping women that's the
most insane thing i've ever heard
but these people have no force of will
so what happens is
you know people like us probably
everybody in this room if someone said
eat a brain we'd be like
no and they'd be like well everyone will
make fun of you if you don't like i
don't care i'm not eating brain
but then you have the other portion of
society where they're like is it the
only way to fit in
okay i'll do it you know first hand i
worked in los angeles and hollywood and
the entertainment industry for like
10 years and i would do these
commercials like and i'd go and read
they'd be like okay
just say i don't care what's in it it
tastes great
and it was everything i didn't believe
and i would do it for the money
and i started to become such a nasty
person it was because i hated myself
for those that that stupid stuff i would
say that i didn't believe and i could
totally see these these
these people doing it not only with
their actions but with their words with
your type of ads but when you hate
yourself you're a good consumer
because you always need to fill that
empty void inside of yourself with empty
chinese-made trinkets
made by slaves caught on credit credit
exactly wouldn't then
it be not a bad thing to get all of
these mass consumer lunatics
to stop buying stuff like the people who
fulfill themselves
by eating brain to prove their worth or
buying things they don't need
shouldn't we be encouraging people to
roll up their sleeves and go chop some
wood
but go outside go outside stop you know
fill up your gas tank stop buying butane
literally just
take some wood cut it up into bits do
the hard work and enjoy the fire with
your friends outside this goes full
circles we were talking about earlier
there's no transcendence in society no
one's living for a higher purpose than
themselves it's like this
hyper-individualistic
hedonistic you know pleasure
self-serving that just corrupts all of
society because really the basis of
society is not really the individual it
should really be the family
the family unit or some kind of group
structure but that's why they're trying
to atomize everyone you know live in
your pod eat your bugs that whole kind
of shtick it's it's disgusting yeah it's
well it's it's mentally deranged
self-absorbed lunatics and i'm to me
that's the definition of of a
congressman
i'm sorry yes because when you look at
their kind of activities you look like
congressman woman that's right whatever
potato potato
uh when you when you look at what
they're doing they're doing the most
insidious ridiculous things to get the
most amount of eyeballs the most amount
of attention that
generates money that generates clicks
that generates you being in a position
of power
they are extremely privileged they are
extremely empowered and for these people
to be on national television playing
like they're the victims
that they're traumatized i mean give me
a break i think it's even more so for
celebrities which are like
neo-aristocrats and so many people look
to them more than they do you know the
congresswoman like aoc who is a
celebrity their own right but
they're the ones who take all these
different impulses in society they were
talking about and put them on steroids
and they're just even heightened i mean
that's why you see the most ridiculous
cases in like page six or whatever it is
because it's just a never-ending cycle
to outdo the previous more
insane instance of whatever it is you in
order to earn points you got to one
you got to one up the next and it's kind
of like you got to eat human brain
because
because of desperation i think people
like your average person are seeking
like attention so that they can get some
money to survive or some resources or
some
attention is kind of a resource too i
think it's because we removed religion
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off
and continue um so politicians are
trying to placate that
desperation by with these social
programs
and it's not working but then it's this
this conversation i feel like is
is becoming circular because it's like
throughout human history we've always
been desperate to survive
we don't we're not owed a living you
know we have to go out and
take it and and it's we've always been
competing to survive against wild
animals or against other humans maybe
i'll i'll say this
we broke ourselves away from that where
now we as
americans especially europeans but all
over the world people who live in luxury
don't have to fight to survive you you
wake up you know there's food
everywhere an insane amount first world
problems yeah first world problems
are all we really have shouldn't people
get back
should like should there's a threshold
we met where we can survive now
can't people just be happy sitting under
the stars with their friends and their
family smiling
and climbing trees we made it animals
don't kill us
randomly now but what i mean is like i
think
i think most of us here really enjoy the
outdoors
starting a fire ian love ian loves
working out ways to start fires on his
own yeah but when i was really poor
i i was hard to love anything i was
obsessed with where am i gonna get my
am i gonna be able to pay rent am i
gonna be out on the street next month
can i afford why do i have to eat this
junk
because i can't afford better food and
it was terrible i think the better food
thing's a myth actually because i was
poor and i ate decently well there's
always going to be i was probably not i
mean
really good now we we buy the best in
such a huge variety of
oils and vinegars and lots of vinegar
like vegetables and all anything we
i don't think we eat the best i mean we
literally have like bacon and bread you
know what i mean it's not like we're
having filet mignon every night or
something i feel very appreciative
i feel luke wants me to order those what
peter lugar luger steaks
honestly we've i've made sure that we
have access to all the
nutrients we need and it's sure sure i i
definitely i definitely can understand
i'm one of those people that enjoys the
little things like i can sit in a room
and with a book and just be happy for
days that's what i mean i mean
you've got a lot of people who live in
cities who are desperate to fit in with
their tribe to earn those social media
points
so i'm not saying like obviously you
know we have a successful business and
we're privileged in that regard
but even you know when i was broke and
living on couches
my fulfillment didn't come from owning
stuff it came from experience with my
friends going in skateboarding getting
that new trick
and just going on adventures to new
places even if it was just walking down
the tracks to see where the tracks went
so many people now are tied to
fulfillment from getting other people to
say they like them
to prove it or to own something to prove
they've got
their car because if they lose their car
life gets harder and they don't want to
lose their i mean when i started my news
organization i literally
was you know not having any money couch
surfing everywhere i had to sleep on the
floor sometimes and it was amazing i had
the best time of my life traveling all
over the world all of the united states
hitching rides
uh hitchhiking here's literally
hitchhiking
uh you know so many places and it was
incredible i want to tell people
your deep your your secret to success oh
dude literally just got on a speedboat
went to epstein island yeah anyone could
have done it yeah
there's a couple journalists that like
literally went around it but like we had
this amazing captain that just surprised
us
wait let me hold on i'm sorry i gotta
clarify luke went to epstein island to
document yes
yes yes yes yes please please please no
misconceptions here
i wasn't an invitee i wasn't invited i
came there to expose the story
yeah where's where's the sense of
adventure where people are satisfied by
just
exploring the woods going for a walk and
like
looking at flowers that's why there's so
much nostalgia in in society because all
the things you remember when you were
kids exploring the woods all that sense
of adventure
and unknown it doesn't exist in the
modern world as an adult anymore for the
most part so there's so much nostalgia
in society
i mean you see it everywhere it does
though yeah it literally does what do
you mean
you could you could look man i'll tell
you you live in new york yeah
uh has is there a burr you've never been
to is there what a borough you've never
been to
no you you've been all the bursts have
you uh
walked every block of staten island i
have not no
you could literally go for a walk
through staten island and i chose that
on purpose because
yeah i don't think i would sleep because
nobody nobody wants that i do know
someone who went every block in
manhattan and they they documented it
was a very cool
cool thing but it's rare it's very rare
no i know i know people who uh i'll be
honest
most the people i know in brooklyn had
never been to the bronx
no joke no joke or staten island yeah i
believe it definitely would have stated
that i wouldn't walk around in the beach
but it's like the way
i think it's it's like the mindset
because it's you can enjoy the shape of
a tree like
the tree branch and like whoa and the
light breaking through it or look at the
clouds
or you can be stressed about what's
coming up in two hours that you gotta be
at that thing so like f this tree it's
like it's kind of like we have so much
information in society you have
wikipedia at your fingertips you can get
everything but there's no interest in
finding that knowledge it's the same
thing you could travel anywhere tomorrow
at least not
there's no there's there's no self
fulfillment there's no drive to do it
though like
i'm fulfilled independently like when i
go skate
i'm skating here for the most part by
myself sometimes adam me and adam will
be skating
but typically i'll go skate you know the
mini ramp and i'll
decide what tricks i want to do for me
by myself and i'm fulfilled by doing it
but i don't look to satisfaction from
any other person like that book bowling
alone with the basically the fall of
like american kind of the
the town and the community and a lot of
the stuff we're talking about it's the
guy bowling alone because it's just like
we've lost kind of bonds with
you know obviously it goes beyond just
what people think of you but there are
bonds being broken with other people
which also gives you value it's not just
always what other people think of you
but there is a benefit to having a
social network that's healthy and
productive
i think we might be too pessimistic
because i think human beings naturally
have this drive to explore and to learn
but a lot of it is just being squashed
out by the school system by government
the mainstream media and now social
media that wants to distinguish
it wants to extinguish this kind of
drive within human beings
don't people have less free time now
than they did like 50 60 years ago i
remember reading a study somewhere i
don't necessarily agree with that
um i don't know if it's true i just
remember but it's probably true in some
context but i'll tell you the saying
goes that
a a poor person today has better dental
care than rockefeller did
at the height of you know his oral oil
bearing shift i
so badly wanted to have kids in my 20s
and travel around the world
with my wife and i didn't have the money
so i didn't
but no one could do that you know what i
mean like people could some
some people could but it doesn't mean
you're entitled to or should expect it
you know what i mean
yeah but i didn't have kids because i
couldn't afford it when when could
anyone ever afford kids
that's amazing you can afford kids it's
it's but it's a it's a myth they're not
that they're like fifty thousand dollars
a year
but it it what about the people who
literally lived in the wilderness
and had kids it's a myth that you can't
afford
okay let's have a kid in you know nine
months so let's get to it no like people
would hook up and have kids and then
they would fight to survive for their
kids
i didn't like to survive like i wanted
to not share i don't know
i'm sorry casey neistat one of the most
successful
individuals in the new internet age had
a kid i think when he was 16
and he was living in a trailer i think
he was homeless at one point and then he
went to become one of the greatest
you know entrepreneurs of this
generation and it's legit
he revolutionized youtube vlogging and
he had a kid well before he was prepared
or capable and he was poor as
as heck but he made it work i think this
idea that you have to have be richer
enough to do it i i don't necessarily
agree
i think the problem is are you fulfilled
internally or externally
and people mostly there's too many
people in this in this world
in this country who are looking for
satisfaction from other they're looking
for
uh they're looking to other people to
validate their existence
instead of validating it on their own
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time